Великі повені - явище природне. І уникнути їх неможливо.
А от мінімізувати збитки - цілком реально, з власного досвіду знають у Німеччині.
Пам'ятки всесвітньої спадщини ЮНЕСКО - під водою.
Саксонська державна опера, Галерея старих майстрів
та знаменита колекція коштовностей в Альбертінумі.
Цим запам'ятався серпень 2002 року в Дрездені.
Коли ж у 2013-му до столиці Саксонії знову прийшла катастрофічна повінь,
удар по місту був значно меншим.
Адже дрезденці, як люблять казати у Німеччині, "зробили домашні завдання".
80 мільйонів євро було інвестовано у профілактику збитків від повеней.
Наприклад, у центрі міста приготували мобільні бар'єри.
І ця дамба врятувала оперу та інші історичні будівлі.
Коли нахлинула вода, 20 отворів у канали розвантажили центр міста.
Здебільшого до повеней призводять зливи.
Коли ґрунт вже перенасичений водою або замерз і не в змозі засвоювати опади,
вода тече у струмки, річки й озера.
І чим менше у русла річки є додаткових відгалуджень, куди б могла піти вода,
тим більше ріка виходить з берегів та охоплює заселену територію.
Тому, перш за все, у Німеччині дбають
про підсилення природних можливостей для затримання води.
Має існувати достатня зелена площа з м'яким ґрунтом,
яка у разі необхідності могла б поглинути надлишок води.
Саме з цією метою у Бонні, наприклад, на південь від центру міста
уздовж Рейну існує величезна лука під назвою Райнауе.
Також німці вважають однією з опор захисту від стихій контрольоване вирубування лісів.
Німеччина належить до країн Європи з найбільшою кількістю дерев.
Водночас у Німеччині, за законом про водне господарство,
заборонено будувати на площах, які затоплюються під час повеней.
І не будь-яких, а повеней століття.
Вони позначаються на відомчих картах і враховуються у будівельному плануванні.
Нехай вас не спантеличує назва "повені століття".
На Рейні дві таких столітніх повені сталися із перервою у лише два роки
- у 1993-му та 1995-му.
Після них наявні доти стандарти захисту від повеней кардинально переглянули,
визначивши нову планку для столітніх повеней - майже 11 метрів.
Саме на стільки піднявся Рейн у 1993-му.
Отож, у районах, куди може зайти повінь, для будівництва або перебудови,
як правило, необхідно консультуватися із місцевим управлінням
водних ресурсів та архітекторами міста.
І ті можуть заборонити розширення будівлі або лісопосадку навіть на приватній ділянці.
Будинок, який знищила повінь, до речі, вже не дозволять побудувати на тому ж місці.
Німці - любителі гідротехнічних споруд.
Вони будують греблі, захисні бар'єри, мобільні стіни або створюють пастки
для річкових потоків у вигляді водосховищ, польдерів та загат.
Чималу роль відіграє прогнозування поведінки течії у разі повені.
Русла річок та струмків розширюють.
Перебудовують дороги та залізничні колії, аби стихія пройшла повз них,
не пошкоджуючи інфраструктуру.
Громадянам, які будують приватні будинки, рекомендують враховувати силу води.
Не лише тієї, яку видно зовні, а й ґрунтових вод.
Каналізація мусить мати клапан, який дозволяє воді виходити назовні,
але зачиняє прохід усередину.
Вікна, двері та усі отвори у будівлях робляться герметичними.
Щоправда, це призводить до ще гірших наслідків у разі підняття ґрунтових вод.
І часто їхній руйнівний потенціал самі німці й недооцінюють.
Під час повені століття у столиці Саксонії у 2002-му ніхто не передбачав,
що ґрунтові води настільки піднімуться.
Не очікували й архітектори гімназії Санкт-Бенно у старому Дрездені.
Під тиском знизу підлога у центрі спортзалу прогинається дугою.
Вчителі, школярі та батьки мішками з піском та баками з водою
намагаються створити противагу.
Однак врешті спортзал доводиться заповнити водою,
аби створити ще більший тиск на нижню плиту.
Підлогу знищено. Але це рятує шкільну будівлю.
Як не парадоксально, але німцям рекомендують заливати власний підвал водою,
якщо підйом ґрунтових вод загрожує стабільності будівлі.
У плануванні конструкцій поряд з річками враховується безліч факторів:
там не можна ставити мазутне опалення та мати електричні установки на нижніх поверхах.
Як не дивно, але держава у Німеччині мінімально допомагає постраждалим
від повеней приватним особам.
Лише найменш заможним і лише по кількасот євро на людину -
точна сума варіюється залежно від федеральної землі.
Ці гроші практично не компенсують втраченого.
Річ у тім, що приватні оселі і майно німцям настійливо рекомендують страхувати.
Так роблять, щоправда, менше половини з них.
У Німеччині тисячі різновидів страховок.
От тільки застрахувати будівлю у районі, якому може загрожувати повінь,
часто невиправдано дорого, а то й узагалі неможливо.
У 1-2 відсотках випадків страхова компанія може відмовити.
Тож жити біля річок хоча й престижно, однак через ризики, пов'язані зі стихією,
власники такого житла мусять готуватися до підвищених витрат.
Утім, скільки б німці не інвестували у захист від водних катастроф,
водночас вони розуміють, що цілком уникнути збитків від повеней неможливо.
І все ж вони не втрачають почуття гумору, а обмінюються порадами та лайфхаками.
Деякі очевидні. Комунікація із сусідами та з рятувальними службами.
Спочатку порятунок людей, а лише потім - речей!
Після повені викликати фахівця, який перевірить пошкоджену водою будівлю на стабільність.
Не їсти овочів та фруктів з території паводка.
А ще - не займатися повеневим туризмом!